IBM Wazi as a service IBM Spectrum
Sentinel and the G2 summer reports all
on this episode of IBM Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
back in February IBM announced plans to
deliver a new era of modernization and
I'm excited to announce that we are
delivering on that promise this week
with the general availability of IBM
Wazi as a service
Wazi as a service gives you self-serve
access to Z OS systems and shortens your
development and testing Cycles you can
now integrate a secure tool chain for
continuous delivery to enhance your
developer productivity
and with increased efficiency and code
development and testing you can reduce
time to Market
Wazi as a service allows you to spin up
a built for purpose zos Devon test
virtual server in six minutes or less
it also helps you shift left and
Implement a continuous testing process
bringing real-time feedback into the
development cycle
the virtual server which runs on real Z
systems Hardware provides up to 15 times
better performance than comparable x86
offerings
with Wazi as a service you can take
advantage of the full value of IBM Z
systems and utilize the agility of IBM
Cloud transforming the software
development lifecycle process for the
Dos applications
to learn more check out the link I've
got in the description of this video
next up let's take a look at the newly
released IBM Spectrum Sentinel Spectrum
Sentinel is a new Cyber resiliency
solution designed to help you enhance
ransomware detection and incident
recovery
Sentinel was developed in response to
specific cyber threat challenges that
our clients are facing across Industries
and geographies
with real-time data monitoring it can
help you identify data breach recover
data in an isolated environment and
restore it in minutes or hours as
opposed to days after a Cyber attack
using IBM's safeguarded copy for IBM
flash system arrays Sentinel frequently
checks data copies for evidence of data
damage caused by malware or ransomware
it then uses safeguarded copy snapshots
to create a secure and isolated backup
ransomware cannot remove alter or
encrypt safeguarded snapshots even with
admin capabilities so in the event of a
Cyber attack these authenticated restore
points Aid in a speedy recovery
to learn more about IBM Spectrum
Sentinel and how it can help you with
cyber resiliency check out the blog link
below
to wrap things up today we are thrilled
to announce that IBM offerings were
featured in more than 800 G2 reports
this translated to over 200 different
leadership awards across various
categories in g2's release of the 2022
summer reports
these reports rank the world's best
software based on authentic timely
reviews from real users breaking down
the latest market trends in technology
and software
leaders are determined based on high
levels of customer satisfaction and
their likeliness to recommend ratings
client satisfaction is at the heart of
IBM's values so we're delighted that we
hold the number one ranking in 54
different reports and we rank in the top
three in an additional 128 reports to
read the feedback and learn more about
the G2 summer reports hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure to explore
the links in the description of this
video and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in Tech now